let's talk about this uh this healthy at
any size they've got this tweet from
Natalie uh demolition Health in any size
is a complete and total lie even if her
shoes are begging even her shoes are
begging her to stop where are her knees
stop celebrating this for f say I feel
really bad for this woman right here
this uh you can't it's hard to see
because of the way the the crop happens
but uh let me see if we can uh show
those feet geez look man this person is
suffering well they're being put on a
platform like it's a good thing and this
this imagine somebody was biting their
own skin off and people were clapping
for them as they did it it's like dude
we need to help these people but we're
coming to this point in our society
where a large faction of people just say
who cares if it feels good it's like uh
if it makes you happy then why the hell
is it so bad it's a horrible ethos a lot
of things make you happy drugs can make
you happy and they destroy your life
this person needed an intervention this
person needed someone to say hey
cut the carbs
lower your salt intake all that stuff go
for a walk instead they said
be you
strap these shoes to your feet and bind
them and then we'll put you on a
magazine ad this person's gonna die
young
I looked up I looked up the definition
of fat phobia on Boston Medical
it's absolutely amazing they're like fat
phobia is deeply ingrained in systemic
racism white supremacy and misogyny the
typical buzzwords buzzword buzzwords
it's all garbage and lies that that is
all just absolute I have to wonder
though man I have to wonder if there
really is a depopulation agenda then uh
we win in the end like the intention of
the people who want there to be less
people is that these people die instead
of helping them because if it's true and
and these powerful Elites are like
there's too many people well here's one
way to get rid of them I am a human
being I am not a monster I will never
ever approve of that and I mean even but
even the depopulation agenda that
targets you know people like this that
are morbidly obese it's not like it just
targets them and we're gonna necessarily
win in the end is because we're still
intaking the seed oils we're still
intaking the bugs at this point we're
gonna intake every single aspect of the
depopulation agenda so it's making us
more unhealthy as we go yeah Tim there
is a depopulation agenda and we're not
going to be the winners of it there's a
lot of these individuals that are
literally and figuratively weighing down
not only our health system but our
entire society and when we look at that
we are going to look at the production
yeah but when we look at especially with
how the population is going to crash how
it's already crashing how fertility
rates are going down uh birth rates are
going down dramatically this is going to
have a significant impact on society
that's going to be very devastating
since there's going to be a lot of older
people not a lot of younger people and
that's going to create a lot of economic
and social chaos that's going to be very
difficult to navigate this is what I'm
saying this morbidly obese woman will
die will die young cancer heart attack
something this morbid obesity is bad for
you heart disease when when these people
who are
given the choice
they are told outright you can be happy
eating whatever garbage you want there
are other people who are like nah I'm
going to take the personal
responsibility and improve my health the
people who choose the personal
responsibility I lost 30 pounds are
going to live a lot longer I I want to
ask you a question when you launched
that 30 pounds did you feel like you did
you feel better in your body right man
like within a week of cutting out sugar
it felt like I had lightning surging
through me when I like I've I've
fluctuated weight before and my heaviest
was 177 right and that was when I was I
was puffy and I'd been eating a lot to
put on weight to get muscle and stuff
and then over the you know course of
like six months after I cut down and I
dropped like 10 pounds
dropping 10 pounds of fat I felt like I
had a brand new body and it was just and
I wasn't particularly heavy you know
it's like I'm not a huge guy but 175 was
too heavy for me dropping 10 pounds I
felt great I can't even imagine what
it's like for someone that loses 50 60
pounds it's like you get a whole new
body new skin suit it wasn't even about
losing the weight it was just cutting
out the sugars and all sudden everything
was improving yeah my blood pressure was
really high it dropped really quickly
just it's just it's just crazy and and
so these are the choices you can make
my point ultimately is
no one is is is forcing this person to
stuff uh food in their in their mouths
right and so what is this what oh
[Laughter]
nobody's forcing people to to live on
healthy lives not to exercise and to uh
endanger their lives the end result
mathematically is quite simple
if you have 100 people and half of them
are inclined to be morbidly obese and
not exercise sterilize their kid and
abort their kids they eventually cease
to exist if the other half is signed
we're gonna have as many kids as
possible we're gonna believe in family
we're going to exercise be healthy and
be responsible they flourish yeah the
end result is obvious yeah but the
problem is when when a sect of humanity
is dying off because it's irrelevant or
or not functionable it will take other
things down with it it's like a flailing
drowning person so you might think once
this ballast is cast off Society will be
better but it's really about how like if
people are we'll see like Mass money
printing to pay for social programs for
people that are severely obese in their
70s and 80s Mass injections of
pharmaceuticals most of most people
don't live that long and and you're
absolutely right there's going to be a
massive burden on the system especially
in the healthcare industry sorry go
ahead well you're just cementing my
point um it could be very very
destructive for people like this to be
let to go which is why it's important
that we call it out when we see it
because it's an addiction I think a lot
of these people are obese because of
sugar addiction or high fructose corn
answer or aspartame addiction or all of
the above combining some new unknown
problem that we're finally seeing you
know with with video and television
obesity yeah I think it's uh phthalates
pcbs so we have a glass bottled water
here at timcast and a variety of
functions of Fashions we have uh the
stuff that we order we do have plastic
water bottles because some people don't
care but uh in the studio we do our own
filtered water we put in glass water
bottles
it's a little things man I have a
feeling that in the future they're going
to start talking about Plastics and in
food the same way we talk about asbestos
yeah oh yeah absolutely well they
already kind of do with I mean you
there's already concerns about micro
Plastics and stuff like that exactly
it's being found in people's blood in
people's lungs yeah and that's one
aspect of it but also a lot of the food
is also being genetically engineered to
hit the pleasure centers of your brain
but actually have no nutritional value
for you and this is why a lot of people
are talking about organ meat this is why
I've been talking about organ meat
specifically because they do have a lot
uh nutritional dense food that is
actually good for you compared to all
the other fluff and nonsense that is
filled with soy and corn they want you
to believe that red meat is what's going
to lead to uh yeah yeah which is
absolutely crazy or that salt is bad or
that fat is bad when in reality what are
they promoting they're promoting high
fructose corn syrup and Seed oils which
which are absolutely inflammatory your
system doesn't know how to handle and
your system is absolutely hijacked by uh
Bill Gates who wants you to have moves
and individuals that that are gamifying
this entire food industry in and also at
the same time believe that there's too
many people in this world that should
that should leave a lot of people
questioning what's going on here as he's
now vaccinating animals yeah and
changing their genetics in order to help
the population where did the seed oil
thing come from this is like a new new
fad that's been taken off well the seed
oil seed oils have been introduced in
the early 1900s specifically by Crisco
and ever since uh Crisco and other seed
oils heavily processed uh you know
inflammatory oils into exactly
essentially it is it is exactly like
engine oil ever since it was introduced
we have seen a skyrocketing of obesity
skyrocketing of heart disease it used to
be rare that people were obese it used
to be rare that the people used to get
heart attacks but ever since the
introduction of seed oils there has been
a correlation with this specific uptick
of people being extremely unhealthy and
dealing with these larger Health
ailmates uh you know health problems
that of course uh now almost more and
more people have have every single day
than they ever had before what do you
think about using the government to like
break up monopolies
dig this like the sugar industry has
commercials where they sell sugar to
kids they used to have tobacco
commercials where they would sell
cigarettes to kids or young adults the
government had to say you can't do that
anymore because hold on Luke the
libertarian party had a guy on stage
talk about selling heroin to kids
with big Pharma one two you look at the
sugar industry they bought off a lot of
the scientists and regulators and they
made a big war on fat now everything's
fat free and everything's filled with
high fructose corn syrup gee I wonder
what would lead to less harm uh some
crackhead selling crack to a small child
or the government what it's doing right
now let's put those let's put those
let's put those got a better one for you
the food pyramid yeah yeah yeah yeah the
government is super healthy when you so
I was looking at the story about there's
a picture showing a bunch of people in
the 60s and they're all like basically
ripped like not right but they're all
thick just naturally and then it's like
what happened and there's a chart
showing Rising obesity rates around the
late 70s and around the same time the
introduction of the food here aspartame
saying like the food pyramid basically
says eat a ton of bread eat a ton of
grains I put those things out and my
I've never felt better okay I'll say it
right now and I'll be I'll be brave I
would rather have a crackhead sell crack
to to a baby then the food pyramid as it
is right now because that would lead to
more people at the end of the day I'm
willing to take that official stance
right here right now can I just ask
everybody to imagine a baby walking up
to a crackhead scratching his face
requesting crack from the crowd selling
the crack rock sell it the baby pulling
five dogs out of its diaper and
requesting I mean someone's got to
animate that but I will say while we're
on the topic of health is you know I
used to I smoke cigarettes for a long
time from a very young age I got off of
cigarettes I went to vaping because it's
marketed as like the good alternative
right I would argue that vaping is
honestly worse for you it's wet Vapor
you're coating your lungs in wet vapor
and it's not nicotine that you're really
being addicted to like when I quit
vaping it was the worst thing that I
probably have ever the worst advice I've
ever gotten off of is you're literally
vaping seed oil soybean oil I mean the
most highly addictive things that you're
already consuming on a regular basis in
your diets and you're doing that in your
lungs consistently over and over and
over again I mean so I'm gonna use this
platform to add okay and say if you're
vaping in the audience it's going to
catch a lot of flack I already know just
quit the first four days if you can make
it past the first four days
you won just just get it out you know
what the point of vaping is it's called
douche fluting for the record everyone
needs to understand that and uh you know
there's there's things you should look
at exactly popcorn lung yeah vitamin E
acetate yeah that was in the dab carts
for a long time I mean that's when you
know Trump I believe is signed the
executive order upping the smoking age
from 18 to 21 is because of the vitamin
E acetate they were making carts at home
and then selling it to children and
people were just popping up a popcorn
long out of sudden see
crack or adjusting popcorn lung well
well again uh it there's many different
scientific terms on this I want to have
to look it back into this because I was
looking into this when I was douche
fluting myself I was smoking cigarettes
and then I got off cigarettes and I
started uh half douche looting half
smoking cigarettes but I still eating
make you feel worse than cigarettes I I
it's hard to tell because they're all
pretty bad for you nicotine though does
have positive effects for your brain and
small very small doses with the paper
that the government mandates for
cigarettes there's uh anti-flame paper
that the government uh makes sure that
all the big tobacco companies use which
is absolutely horrible for you as well
you're vaping metal particles I just
want to recommend for people
um there's a great book uh the easy way
to quit smoking I tried everything to
quit smoking nothing worked but I read
that book and it actually helped me and
showers stopped it and I stopped cold
turkey and it was very easy the easy way
to quit smoking what's popcorn yeah
there was a there was a two years ago
there was a bit of uh maybe three years
ago at this point it came out the
vitamin E acetate was in the nicotine
Vapes and causing what they call popcorn
among also known as bronchiolitis
obliterins or obliterative bronchiolitis
that's the word yeah it's a disease that
results in the obstruction of the
smallest Airways of the lungs the
bronchiolus due to inflammation
wow well I mean you got to think if
you're consistently and it's not just
vitamin E acetate either that can cause
this stuff but that was a large
occurrence and that's what they actually
studied is if you're inhaling metal seed
oil soybean oil and Laura I mean a lot
of it's like propylene glycol glycerin
into your lungs on a regular basis more
often than cigarettes because it doesn't
make you stink it actually makes you
smell good A lot of them are fruity
flavors you can hit it discreetly when
you're in restaurants when you're in
your house anything anywhere you want I
mean you're doing this on a regular
basis taking hundreds to thousands of
hits a day your body I mean all things
in moderation your body is not going to
have a good reaction to smoke filled
with all these chemicals and toxins
entering you over and over again can we
just bring back Natural Tobacco and
crackers
listen guys guys I smoked cigarettes for
longer than Taylor's been alive and I
disagree strongly cigarettes are the
worst damn things in the world now I'm
not saying that vaping is good but I
don't want people to get the impression
that I'm sitting here saying that
smoking is is not as bad at vaping
without all of it's terrible at least
saying something smoking is the worst
thing in the world I smoke like I said
smoke for almost 30 years it was the
hardest thing to quit I don't I haven't
had a drink I quit drinking five years
ago and it was the easiest thing in the
world to do I for me personally I know
that it's not everybody else I
understand that people have different
situations but for me it was easy
smoking cigarettes if I'm around people
that smoke too much I'm not the guy
that's like oh get that away that's
awful I'm like I'm gonna beat you up and
take them all go away because they're
it's it's such nicotine is such a a mask
you're smoking the fillers the Arsenic
all of the nasty things that they put in
those papers
and it was one of the hardest thing to
quit one of the hardest things that I
mean is you're angry you want to just
strangle somebody and a lot of it is
psychological a lot of this is in your
head a lot of this is subconscious
because of all the propaganda everywhere
that you don't realize but again reading
that book changed my life made me quit I
don't want to smoke people are smoking
around me I'm like I don't even care
anymore if you haven't read that book
the easy way to quit smoking I can't
recommend it enough what's what's the
easy way you like you read the book and
it in the book it tells you hey you
could smoke as you're reading this and
then it it it it it breaks down all the
propaganda to why you're smoking it
breaks down all the bull crap it breaks
down all the marketing and all the lies
that could that you convince yourself
that makes you want to smoke and then
you kind of unwind with the propaganda
in your head as you're reading this book
as you're smoking and at the end of the
book you're like I just don't want to
smoke what the easiest thing for me to
quit was I remember I went on a hike and
I had just like went off on a little
tour and you know I used to I used to be
very athletic uh you know in high school
and I used to do bodybuilding I used to
do the whole nine yards and I climbed
you know about 20 rocks off this trail
and I got to the top and I felt like my
lungs were going to explode and ever
since that day I didn't hit a vape I
just it was like a almost a switch being
flipped into my head it was like okay
this is I can actually see that it's
affecting me now and it it was very very
hard I mean the first week I literally
wanted to kill somebody I mean the anger
is incredible I found that too with
cutting addiction is uh with a purpose
like I had gained weight when I was 23
24 I was eating a lot of McDonald's for
lunch and drinking a lot of Pepsi or
Coke or whatever and I gained like 20
pounds for the first time my life I was
160 and I was like man I look fat I
can't be an actor if I'm fat I can't so
I have to not be fat if you have a
reason it makes things a lot easier
um did you ever roll your own cigarettes
or not oh uh like just buy tobacco just
pure tobacco I like those I mean I
understand the addictive nature and
obviously the carcinogens involved with
burning anything and inhaling it but
like without the filters which I've
heard have this not didn't have asbestos
in the 50s they had cigarettes that had
asbestos in the filters so imagine what
they don't know how bad is for you now
and that stuff they have fiberglass in
there cut up the inside your lungs
always one stream faster the fiberglass
was that the uh the crack ones or
whatever I think yeah I do think it was
like the camel crushes things like that
so it adds flavor to it but in reality
you're just sucking down glass and it
gets you higher faster and more addicted
quicker because it's getting in your
bloodstream faster thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time